bienvenue à tous dans ce pilote dans cet
épisode de 1.2 du salon de thé puisque
nous avions déjà essayé de mener ce
premier salon t la connexion s'était
retrouvé un petit peu à genoux quoi
chose promise chose due nous sommes de
retour avec la merveilleuse valentine de
science de comptoir avant monde et avant
même qu'on commence à parler je vous
propose de découvrir sa chaîne qui
devrait vous donner un bon aperçu de
pourquoi nous sommes là aujourd'hui
donc le principe c'est que chaque
libéral réels ceux qui sont en dessous
de lui si je prends ce croire améthyste
de dureté 7 et se gypse de dureté 2 est
bien celui-là variés celui ci comme vous
pouvez le voir ici
l'inversé n'est pas vrai
le gif ne peut pas non plus une
oreillette parce que je suis parler les
râles par contre je peux le rayer à
l'ongle regardez-moi ça et voilà c'est
donc un extrait de science de comptoir
qui est la chaîne des valentins bonjour
bonjour est ce que tu veux te présenter
présenter ta chaîne pour les personnes
qui ne les connaîtraient pas encore
oui alors je m'appelle valentine je suis
journaliste scientifique et vidéaste et
du coup je tiens ma chaîne 100 au
comptoir
jusqu'ici sa mort ce que l'accès kimi
qui parle alors au départ ça parlait
d'un peu plein de trucs et la
spécifiquement ça s'est recentré sur la
géologie voilà donc j'apprends à comment
les chais des cailloux comment les rayer
comment on fabrique du sable voilà plein
de choses extraordinaires comme tu l'a
bien dit récemment nous sommes enfin
voilà les téléthons background
scientifique alors à la base j'ai une
licence en géologie
après je suis revenu dans le droit
chemin donc j'ai fait un master en
écologie afin de loger voltige après
j'ai fait une année de césure et un
autre master en journalisme scientifique
et voient leur cours alors il ya du loup
qui dit bonjour à tous de quoi on va
parler aujourd'hui mais dites donc c'est
merveilleux parce que c'est exactement
ce que j'allais annoncer aujourd'hui on
va parler de l'humour et la manière de
rendre un propos divertissant pour un
acteur ou un spectateur en communication
scientifique on va pas parler de
l'humour utilisé contre certaines
communautés conspirationnistes anti
vaccins et autres on va vraiment être
sûr de l'humour qui sublime le contenu
plutôt que de dénigrer des communautés
parce qu'on est des gens bien et que la
bienveillance c'est important l'humour
comme outil donne dans l'éducation c'est
quelque chose qui est qui je pense a
toujours existé mais qui se fait
d'autant plus prévalents aujourd'hui
notamment avec l'émergence des chaînes
youtube notamment la chaîne de valentine
mais pas uniquement on voit que les eaux
grasses et s'y adonne avec avec moult
joie on à la notion déduites aint ou des
du musulman en français qui est un
merveilleux francis mme
franquisme france et six voitures quand
suicide même si je sais pas récemment
mais il faut savoir que en dans les
années 70 notamment on a on a eu une
montée des études sur l'humour et
l'éducation qui ont commencé à
apparaître en 1979 on avait le
trimestriel impact force à mpack tove
jansson société dionis co qui consacrait
un numéro entier à l'humour on parle
déjà cette époque d'humoristes
scientifique est ce que j'aime bien
c'est que l'éditorial porte le titre
respect n'ont pas peur ou dévotion et il
s'exprime ainsi dit la science a encore
un gros travail de relations publiques à
accomplir pour beaucoup elle est soit un
mystère insondable un monstre dans une
blouse blanche ainsi que nous l'avons
attendu décrite ou un temple sacré et
reproche à certains scientifiques et de
participer à ce courant de pensée par à
tous mais à certains en considérant la
science comme une discipline si pure
qu'elle devrait être passés hors
d'atteinte des profanes
donc il poursuit le travail de relations
publiques que la science doit accomplir
consiste à se mêler aux flux de la vie
quotidienne à s'humaniser à être mise en
contexte et l'humour est probablement
l'outil d'humanisation le plus important
donc pour lui l'humour il sert avant
tout à prendre du recul il permet de
digérer non seulement ce qu'apporte la
science mais aussi je reprends ses
termes un ce qu'apporte la vie parce
qu'on était quand même dans une période
où on sortait d'une guerre il y avait la
guerre froide a dit oui la bombe
nucléaire donc c'est vrai que c'est
l'humour a pris une place très
importante à l'époque pour rétablir un
lien de confiance entre les
scientifiques et le public mais aussi
pour apporter de la connaissance
scientifique je sais pas si toi tu t'es
déjà servi de l'humour pour désamorcer
un sujet qui pouvait être un petit peu
compliqué en sciences que ce soit dans
la communication sur twitter ou sur
youtube bas en sciences jeu là comme ça
j'ai pas d'exemple mais c'est un truc
que j'aime bien faire en ce moment oui
parce que ça ne serait ce que pendant le
confinement pendant la bienvenue au
début de toute cette histoire bukovine
n'était tout simplement un peu la
panique même si je perds tu es d'avoir
utilisé ce nom là
mais et après il ya quelques jours de
délai et après les gens commencent à
faire des blagues à plein de même qu'ils
sont sortis d'être comme ça et j'ai
l'impression que l'on sait qu'ils
beaucoup détendu grâce à lui mots alors
que la situation était toujours aussi
grave qu et c'est un des rôles de
l'humour justement parce que j'ai fait
quelques petites recherches dessus pour
pour une vidéo en fait cette différents
types d'humour vous pouvez tester il ya
un site qui a été fait par des
psychologues qui s'appelle humeur
style.com est comme ça vous pouvez
répondre à un questionnaire et vous
voyez est elle le type d'humour que vous
utilisez et dans le lot il ya un type
d'humour qui permet justement de de
prendre en dérision ce qui nous arrive
et du coup de mieux mieux mieux vivre
les événements dramatiques convives et
je trouve que l'humour est vraiment très
utile super important et c'est très
intéressant je connaissais pas je vais
aller regarder ça je sais pas si je
devrais recommandé le rire de bergson
parce qu'en vrai je n'ai pas lu mais
sachez qu'il y fit le soft qui se
rappelle personne qui écrit tout un
bouquin sur le rire et je suis sûr que
c'est le carrément adapté pour cet
épisode est dans ma bibliothèque je n'ai
pas encore lu wilson biotech
il ya un truc qui demandent quel est ton
jeu les villages et les demandes ont
même pensé voilà je je vais te laisser
faire à la recommandation voilà je te
laisse met on cacher dessus non mais je
le recommande
après justifie pas tellement ce qu'ils
racontent mais sur le principe sûr
qu'elle a eu de très bonnes intuitions
de trucks ont été reprises sur après
parlée par les sociologues par les
biologistes évolutif par plein de gens
il a eu effectivement de très beaux
bonnes intuitions sur le rôle du rire
pourquoi on rigole pourquoi on se moque
des gens et des trucs qui passe plus du
tout aujourd'hui gens quittent quand il
parle de la caricature il ya des banques
ne peut pas provoquer surtout que je
parce que sinon ça voilà il parle de
sujets qui passeraient plus du tout
aujourd'hui et étudie mince mais comment
on pouvait rire d'autres à l'époque quoi
c'est intéressant n'est pas vrai je vous
en dis ça brasse si ça se trouve les
gens s'indigneront du fait qu'on ait pu
rire du coc vide dans un siècle à savoir
il ya un truc qui demandent quels sont
tes inspirations pour pour l'humour que
tu mets dans tes vidéos
alors mes inspirations
c'est essentiellement d'humour absurde
anglais donc
j'aime beaucoup les monty python j'aime
beaucoup des séries comme haïti crowd
little britain que je vous recommande
chaudement little britain s'est
directement inspiré des monty python en
fait ces deux acteurs qui se grime en
plein d'acteurs différents enfin en
plein de personnages différents et qui
jouent des petites saynètes comme ça et
c'est à mourir de rire à chaque fois
donc il ya ça il ya en français il ya
les nuls
les robins des bois bien sûr enfin voilà
ce genre de réponse
et du coup qu'est ce qui t'a est ce qu
est ce que tu as des personnes ou des
dés des choses qui tout ramener à mêler
la science et d'humour spécifiquement
alors oui disons qu'à la base j'ai
toujours été un peu du genre à vouloir
mettre des blagues même quand il fallait
pas genre dans mes articles
journalistiques dans les devoirs granby
à l'école dans les pubs mais mes oraux
de mes oraux de recherche en master où
les gens étaient pas très sérieux oui
pour jour quand j'ai fait ça pour moi
c'est moi et moi je faisais les grosses
blagues est cool et jury était mort de
rire je me dis plutôt ça a joué des
tours et en fait non jean réussite est
content et j'ai des bonnes notes donc je
suis donc pas pourquoi pas en fait c'est
pas incompatibles et sa nation c'est
lourd et après sur youtube j'étais
relativement plus frileuse au début
parce que youtube c'est un peu le temple
de l'humour et il ya plein de gens qui
disaient ne vous lancez pas ne vous
forcez pas à faire des blagues sur
youtube quoi enfin je sais pas c'est pas
utile surtout si vous faites de la
vulgarisation et nous nous sommes
étudiants oui j'avais compris c'est à
l'envers en me disant bon faut pas faire
de blagues ou être du coup il ya un truc
est équipé off qui collait pas compris
moi enfin par rapport à ma personnalité
et j'ai des amis notamment charlotte que
je savais qu'ils m'ont dit pourquoi tu
est coincés comme ça dans tes vidéos
pourquoi tu veux pas juste faire comme
tu es dans la vraie vie et c'est là où
est arrivée la première vidéo de
géologie pourquoi les géologues l'âge
des cailloux et je dis moi ça m'a
beaucoup beaucoup plus amusé à le faire
changer pas du tout considéré ça comme
on travaille en fait même si sa demande
est beaucoup de boulot s'est passé comme
ça et il ya eu un très bon accueil par
le public donc je me suis dit bon bah
c'est bon j'ai trouvé mon crayon titi
c'est qu'il est j'ai continué comme ça
et je vais de plus en plus loin encore
les blagues et je fais
correct et et ça plaît quand même donc
je sais pas quand je vais m'arrêter
parce que faut pas m'encourager comme ça
il ya nicolas qui dit bravo séances de
contes arts pour ta chaîne donc c'est
que finalement ça déplaît pas transcrit
ça tu disais qu'il y avait eu beaucoup
de travail
comment je vais poser la question
comment est-ce que tu as réussi à faire
évoluer l'humour qui te vient
spontanément pour en faire un outil
police
enfin poli au sens de com comment
pauline est un caillou parce que
l'humour de la peau contre toutes les
formes
comment est-ce que tu as réussi à le
faire évoluer comme un outil qu'elle
comment est ce que tu écris tes textes
de manière à mettre l'humour à
contribution de façon intelligente et
efficace
alors je pense qu'il ya une grosse
grosse part de spontané une feinte de
spontanéité parce que quand je raconte
un fait scientifique une anecdote comme
ça à des amis ou ma même à quelqu'un de
ma famille je balance forcément plein de
bac 2 dans ça ne viendrait pas de le
formuler autrement donc c'est pas un
effort pour moi après il ya des éléments
qui me font dire que j'essaie quand même
de préparer un peu certaines blagues
pour pouvoir les mettre dans le script
notamment depuis que je travaille avec
un promoteur
bon ça fait une vidéo mais j'ai fait
aussi d'autres vidéos sur qui vont
arriver avec le vortex notamment gars
avec un prompteur et du coup la baguette
n'a pas tellement le droit a enfin tu
peux être un peu spontané mais il faut
quand même préparé quelques trucs donc
j'ai préparé quelques blagues en réserve
et je me suis dit que ça marchait bien
cette espèce de contrat et il ya un
autre truc aussi que sur lequel j'essaie
de jouer c'est de mettre des blagues à
la fois dans le texte est à la fois dans
le visuel box dans le visuel ça peut
être juste quand je quand je tombe à un
moment où le train express est aussi
grossier que ça mais en gros et dans le
texte parce que je pense tout simplement
à l'accessibilité
si on me regarde sans l'image ou alors
si c'est quelqu'un de mal voyants qu'ils
me regardent et ben je veux quand même
qu'il est et l'information et quelques
blagues et appareils 6 et des
malentendants quand tu parlais des
visuels il ya une partie de des blagues
qui se créent au montage ou sait des
choses que tu avais déjà en tête en
attendant s'inscrit plaque en montage il
ya plusieurs étapes en fait il ya quand
j'ai écrit le script j'essaie de mettre
des blagues dedans j'essaye de ce legs
les deux puisqu'ils viennent en tête
quand j'écris
[Rires]
dès que vous quand j'essaie de deux
mètres des blacks dans le script voilà
après au tournage il peut y avoir des
bloopers des bêtises comme ça je les
laisse pas ce que ça me fait rire et et
au montage évidemment au montage c'est
une réécriture du truc et et j'aime
beaucoup en fait je trouve ça un peu je
suis peut-être un peu psycho-pop
commandes
bon bref un truc sur les banques c'est à
dire que je me des doubles et là moi du
montage aime beaucoup faire des blagues
à la mois du tournage
c'est tellement une espèce de petite
facture de la personnalité alors on a
comment il s'appelle macal barn qui dit
aux sciences de comptoir jort hng les
découvertes avec les eaux grasses et qui
en parlait il ya peu en live au bas
merci beaucoup et ben arfa se dire que
c'est comme utiliser l'humour dans
l'éducation ça date pas d'aujourd'hui on
a alors je sais pas si vous connaissez
charles johnson johnson c'est un
mathématicien mais si je vous dis son
nom de plume ça vous dira peut-être
quelque chose c'est louise carole
l'auteur d'alice au pays des merveilles
il était très connu pour ses blagues
c'était quelqu'un alors c'est une
information un petit peu controversé qui
avait beaucoup d'amis enfants à qui il
écrivait des lettres
rien ne prouve aujourd'hui que louise
carroll était un pédophile je ne me
prononcerai pas de façon de trancher sur
la question mais façon pour sa part est
l'homme de l'art exactement je pense que
c'est quelque chose de très important
pour ne pas se gâcher 90% des des choses
qui sont produites aujourd'hui et par le
passé et il utilisait beaucoup l'humour
et les puzzles et d'énigmes pour pour
enseigner aux enfants
c'était super c'était super intéressant
enfin c'est super intéressant de voir
c'est de devoir ces lettres et de les
lire c'est vraiment hyper distrayant on
avait aussi si on remonte un demi siècle
on avait un mépris des vies qui était un
inventeur de génie sur lequel je vous
invite à vous renseigner qui amuse et le
le d'histoire de la royal institution il
avait même créé des fêtes de gaz
hilarant auquel il invité l'élite
anglaise il avait découvert l'usagé du
gaz hilarant qui avait été synthétisées
par presley au début du 18e enfin au
milieu du xviiie siècle et il y avait
des fêtes qui s'organise et où les gens
se prenaient des fuites de gaz hilarant
et se marrer ce marin ensemble ça a
donné lieu à tout un tout de suite de
mode et juste comme les dix neuvième
siècle on avait des soirées afin d
espèces d'événements de spectacles de
gaz hilarant où les gens se bouffer des
murs où il courait partout en délire
voilà c'était c'était le lol oui ou non
on est d'accord là la drogue c'est mal
et ne prenait pas de gaz hilarant parce
que vous risquez de temps respirer
tellement que vous ne pourrez plus enfin
ça c'est super important que non mais
enfin par exemple mais toi un 10 km
heure il ya aujourd'hui en particulier
en angleterre des gens qui se font des
soirées au gaz hilarant sauf qu'ils en
respire tellement qu'ils en oublient de
respirer de l'oxygène et ils peuvent
tomber dans le coma donc faites
attention aux âmes et rigolo mais
regardez plutôt des vidéos drôles aller
voir valentine jacques sa chaîne tout
simplement
et puis quand il en aura plus vous allez
voir les pistons parce que je ne peux
que valider cette toile cette référence
les études elle montre que l'humour il a
des bénéfices pour la mémoire dès le
plus jeune âge c'est assez assez épatant
on a des études qui sont faites avec des
bébés d'un an et demi où on voit que
déjà ça renforce la mémoire ça renforce
aussi la tension l'engagement la
compréhension de l'information les
émotions positives associé à
l'apprentissage qui du coup renforce à
leur tour la mémorisation
c'est assez assez épatant je vous ai mis
quelques europe quelques extraits de
d'études que j'ai pu trouver en ligne
sur le sujet ça n'est vraiment qu'un
tout petit aperçu de ce qui a été publié
c'est quelque chose qui a beaucoup
intéressé comme je vous ai dit les
scientifiques dans les années 70 ça a
été abandonnée puis dans les années 2000
ça a fait un retour en force et il ya
beaucoup de contenu qui a été publié sur
sur le sujet ça permet aussi de
décomplexifier enfin de décomplexer
pardon l'apprentissage on a beaucoup de
culpabilité qui peut être associé à l
incapacité à comprendre tel ou tel sujet
c'est vrai que l'humour apporte une
certaine dose de détente
moi je sais que je le constate avec tes
vidéos enfin un petit jeu sam est
vachement moins la pression tout de
suite parce qu'on se dit ok ok ça va
être drôle ça va être bien que j'ai en
fait on se fait à mener 30
mans vers le sud ont fait et j'ai tout
compris c'est génial ça même si la
géologie sec malgré science dans
certaines personnes mais bon je peux
entrer n'y a pas grand chose à
comprendre
alors moi je vais vous montrer un
extrait de vidéo il y en a beaucoup des
extraits de vidéos qu'on peut trouver
sur les sciences et l'humour mais j'en
avais trouvé un que j'aime énormément
parce que c'est james trendy qui est un
spécialiste du 10 boeing qui aime
beaucoup dit bonne qu'elle est les
magiciens les charlatans qui fait ça
avec de l'humour
et là il le fait avec les chirurgiens
philippins et la vidéo est vraiment à
mourir de rire je vous propose d'en
découvrir un extrait et j'aurai le micro
voilà donc ça c'est james wendy qui est
vraiment un gars que j'aime beaucoup
parmi les autres références que j'aime
énormément vous avez tom l'erreur qui
est un chansonnier scientifique c'était
un mathématicien à dire vrai qui
écrivait des chansons sur les sciences
et sur les débats un peu polémique de
son époque sur la bombe sur le plagiat
dans les mathématiques sur sur la guerre
etc
et je vous recommande vivement d'aller
l'écouter je vous noté son ombre dans le
dans le tchat
il s'avère que son nom veut dire
d'ailleurs professeur de ce que j'en ai
lu ce qui est tout à fait providentiel
je ne sais pas si toi tu as des
références particulière en termes de
d'humoristes scientifique que tu
aimerais comme entame d'humoristes
scientifique
j'en connais pas des masses mais j'ai pu
voir mike bird en spectacle qui est
vraiment enfin c'est impressionnant quoi
c'est une nouvelle façon de présenter la
science et j'étais vraiment bluffé et ça
m'a donné envie de me faire justement de
cette petite astuce scénique donc je
pense ça peut être assez sympa donc à
lui je crois que son spectacle est sorti
en dvd ou alors il va sortir dans pas
longtemps et il ya aussi un autre
humoriste entier que j'ai pu voir en
spectacle sur scène je continuais qui
s'appelle damien jayat et et c'était
ultra bien ce qu'ils faisaient comment
est ce que tu écris sont là puisse le
mettre dans le chat alors je vais
essayer d'écrire bande à kombouaré super
up
or si ça marche damien jayat je sais pas
s'il faut encore quelque chose mais il
est médiateur scientifique et humoriste
identifier il a fait une tournée dans
toute la france et quelques années et
c'était vraiment bien ce qu'ils je peux
plus du tout dire sur quatre sujets que
c'était mais j'ai bien rigolé déjà plus
d'époque
il ya de ces loups qui jean max bert des
géniales son spectacle est disponible
sur les plates formes des replays pour
ceux que ça intéresse je ne donne pas le
bas ventre je vous invite à aller voir
ça ouais en podcast ce que j'aime
énormément s'est payé une fenêtre manqué
cage de la bbc bon c'est en anglais un
malheureusement pour ceux qui ne parlent
pas anglais mais ça fait ça a été un des
premiers podcast je crois à parler
justement des humoristes et de la
science est ce qu'ils ont est-ce qu'ils
ont lieu d'être d'être mélangés ou pas
et c'est justement la question que je
voulais te poser est ce que selon toi la
science et l'humour devrait être
mélangés ou est-ce qu'il faut tenir l'un
à l'égard de l'autre c'est une question
complètement biaisé un coup la
rhétorique mais bon oui je pense qu'il
peut tenir l'un et l'autre bien préparé
voilà pas déconner non mais la femme
cela merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivis
disons que devoir devoir non fait ce
qu'on veut quoi mais simplement c'est un
outil comme un autre pour vulgariser et
je trouve quand même diablement efficace
alors pas forcément pour faire passer
une information sur tille compliqué
parce que j'ai remarqué il ya pas mal de
commentaires sur ma chaîne kingdom qui
me disent qu'est-ce que j'ai rigolé mais
par contre je n'ai jamais écouté par ce
qui fait par contre qu'ils regardent de
trois fois mes vidéos donc ça c'est bon
pour mes stats mais après je pense que
les gens s'en souviennent beaucoup plus
même s'ils se souviennent pas dans le
détail du raisonnement ils se
souviennent que l'information est là et
du coup ils peuvent revenir la chercher
s'ils veulent ils se souviennent que les
géologues ne tiennent pas forcément
pourquoi ces délinquants des parts et
voilà si je me souviens qu'on laisse un
caillou pour savoir si c'est un fossile
c'est grâce aux mésaventures y ait de la
science rédigé par jim jordan que je
salue avec qui nous travaillons sur un
projet de livre
je vous en dirai plus lorsque nous en
saurons plus est
clairement ça a permis de faire passer
l'information mais comme tu dis les
informations complexes ça peut devenir
un petit peu compliqué mais quelle
qu'elle ressort fonctionne selon toi
plus que d'autres
est-ce que c'est plutôt de l'humour
visuel est ce que ça va être des blagues
est ce que ça va être de l'ironie de la
dédramatisation c'est vraiment difficile
à dire ça dépend des gens ont ça dépend
de de toi même je pense pas que ça
dépend du sujet spécialement quand on
pourrait faire un jeu où tu dois tirer
au sort un type d'humour et une
information à vulgariser et je pense que
tu arriveras toujours à faire quelque
chose avec quoi
si l'info est pas trop trop compliqué
mais ouais ça dépend des gens moi je
pense qu'il faut varier et faire un pot
de clôture des deux ressorts préféré que
tu utilises sur ta chaîne des ressorts
préféré bel humour absurde beaucoup ce
qui est en déroute plus dense
sinon vraiment dans le détail ce que
j'aime bien c'est faire des énumérations
qui n'en finissent pas et qui avec des
trucs qui n'ont rien à voir les uns avec
les autres et surtout rien à voir avec
ou des fois je remette d une énumération
qui tient la route avec un intrus de
danse à jeu j'aime beaucoup beaucoup ce
procédé j'utilise un petit peu trop et à
lesparre et valentine dans les
commentaires en bas d'un an
ça ne devait pas dans la liste ça c'est
bon pour ses stats
est ce que tu as déjà réussi à faire
changer d'avis une personne qui était
récalcitrante aux sciences avec l'humour
alors récalcitrante aux sciences je
pourrais pas te dire parce que je touche
pas tellement ce public là je pense par
contre il ya deux choses qui me place
c'est un jeu c'est à dire de la bonne
manière mais je touche des enfants
il m'arrive de toucher un public jeune
georges et disclaimer numéro deux et a
déjà des enfants s'il vous plaît
j'espère que personne n'aura l'idée de
clips et donc il ya un festival une fois
il ya un petit enfant qui avait enfin
petite enfance est horrible d'être à un
jeune d'une dizaine d'années qui étaient
là et j'étais en train de discuter avec
d'autres vidéaste et en fait ils
attendaient pour se prendre en photo
avec moi je sais pas ce qu'ils voient là
donc il ya des jeunes qui à coups de
machette donc ça ça me fait hyper
plaisir et puis
j'ai remarqué que ça a aidé à changer
l'opinion que les gens arrivaient sur la
géologie
parce que à la base c'était une science
qui est enfin c'est une force qui est
même pas spécialement considéré par le
grand public ni par mes collègues et est
parce que bon c'est des cailloux qu'est
ce que tu veux raconter battue et j'ai
remarqué que enfin j'ai eu des retours
dans ce sens qui ne dit bah en fait
c'est une science et enfin il ya des
trucs intéressants en tirer donc si
jamais ça une image un peu plus positif
de 2 ça c'est tout bénef c'était mon but
premier c'est important enfin dans mon
but premier c'était de faire des blagues
donc sachez que si vous allez sur la
science de valentine ses priorités c'est
l'humour et ensuite on fera un peu de
chance cela c'est un point de vue
dialogue finalement c'est tout ce qu'il
fallait en attend est-ce que non mais le
pire c'est que c'est ça c'est que si on
me dit que qu'on a bien rigolé ça me
fait beaucoup plus plaisir que j'ai bien
appris je me suis trompé de voces c'est
pas bien j'en suis pas sûr non je pense
que vu le succès vu l'enthousiasmé des
gens dans le chat je pense que tu es
exactement là où tu devrais trouver
est ce qu'on a déjà reproché de manquer
de rigueur simplement parce que tu
faisais trop de blagues sk déjà des gens
qui t'ont dit soit c'est un sujet
sérieux tu devrais pas plaisanter ou ok
c'est rigolo mais t'es qui alors non
j'ai pas eu ce genre de retour mais je
pense que quand il si jamais regarder
une vidéo en entier ils disent que je
suis récupérables donc de toutes façons
à la limite du mot barrière quoi
par contre j'ai eu des retours dans le
sens où on faisait des blagues qui était
vraiment passé et là on m'a dit oh tu
vas un peu trop long et en même temps
ces mêmes blagues là qui plaisent
beaucoup aux nôtres donc en gros je suis
quand tu dis pas les noms pour des
jeunes qui les aideront d'ambiguïté noms
qui vont trop loin des blagues sur sur
les migrants sur les diverses
communautés ne creusons pas plus loin on
a déjà parlé de drogue et dans 117
enfants qu'on touche donc bon on va se
prendre aux tripes australie où et
comment est-ce que tu arrives à faire
entendre enfin
on en avait déjà parlé par un premier
épisode voilà du coup je leur pose des
questions désolé pour ceux qui étaient
déjà là comment est-ce que tu arrives à
faire comprendre dans ton canton script
de la distinction entre une information
une blague comment est-ce que tu arrives
à véhiculer le fait que là on est sur
une information sérieuse et que d'un
autre côté on est sur une plaisanterie
eh ben c'est une de mes questionnements
dernièrement je ne sais pas comment les
gens arrivent à faire la différence en
fait moi spontanément j'essaye de
d'appuyer un peu le fait que c'est une
blague
sans faire non plus lol on rigole ou tu
vois m à un disclaimer en bas je rigole
mais aussi des fois j'ai dépensé moment
plaît mais ouais c'est ça c'est sérieux
c'est pas sérieux
mais ouais j'essaye de faire des têtes
un peu qui laisse comprendre que c'est
bis ronnie et ou de faire des trucs
tellement gros que tu ne dis pas que
c'est vrai en fait mais c'est vrai que
même dans la vie quotidienne j'ai ce
problème la dg beaucoup de gens qui me
prennent au sérieux alors je dis que des
conneries il ya antoine vit beaucoup moi
je souris pas c'est que c'est que c'est
sérieux mais en fait tu souris tout le
temps donc ça marche pas ah oui d'abord
je suis vous de temps et ensuite je fais
des blagues en gardant une pokerface
donc ça va il semble je sais plus où
j'avais vu ça mais c'est plus c'était
dans une série où si c'était vraiment
youtuber qui mettait une petite lumière
rouge en route son écran à chaque fois
qu'il faisait une blague
c'était super dhr c'est un petit michael
bastian que des fois il essaie un blanc
et puis tu avais le rouge qui sait et
c'est à dire honni je verrai comment est
ce que selon toi on trouve un enfin on a
commencé un petit peu abordé des pistes
mais comment est ce qu'on arrive à
trouver un équilibre entre l'humour et
la rigueur dans ces vidéos pour ne pas
se décrédibiliser ou décrédibiliser la
recherche scientifique comment est ce
qu'on trouve un juste milieu
tu demandes à celle qui fait des blagues
sur les migros in and alors pour le coup
jusqu'aux vont tes blagues ça ne dépend
que de toi mais c'est plutôt les blagues
en lien avec la science comment est ce
qu'on arrive à rappeler que c'est
quelque chose d'important que qui a
quand même de ce fait de chute sérieuse
qui sont faites derrière
comment est ce que toi tu rêves oui oui
effectivement c'est le fait de de citer
ses sources
de dire tout ça vient si les gens
regardent dans la description de ma
dernière vidéo il ya chez pas à 45 ans
fin de l'année oui c'est un milieu où il
ya une trentaine de sources je regarde
c'est des sites sérieuses et des études
scientifiques c'est des bouquins de
sciences voilà bon c'est du wikipédia
aussi un petit peu parce que vous ne
passent tous par là mais mais je pense
que l'important c'est d'avoir des
sources qui tienne la route
j'ai des relecteurs aussi je vais relire
chacun de mes scripts par un expert donc
un géologue
car les vrais géologue et puis ça va
plus je vais avoir du mal à trouver des
géologues qui supporteront duboscq a
peut-être leurs électeurs de la dernière
vidéo tu avais une vidéo donc on verra
mais je pense c'est important de rester
sérieux sur le fond même si on peut on
peut déconner sur la forme parce que bon
on est sur youtube quoi c'est pas une
soutenance de thèse
voilà est-ce que tu penses que tu étais
vidéo arrive à véhiculer l'idée aux gens
qu'ils qu'il faut prendre l'a6 enfin
qu'il faut nous mais que que la science
reste quelque chose de sérieux est ce
que tu penses que tu arrives à véhiculer
un petit peu de cette fameuse méthode
scientifique aux gens à travers tes
vidéos alors la méthode scientifique en
général je sais pas trop par contre j'ai
c'est de véhicules et je vais dire un
truc mais c'est hypocrite parce que je
crois pas que je les fais encore mais
dans l'idée j'aimerais essayer de
véhicules et d'abord les différentes
facettes qu'on trouve dans la géologie
donc il ya si vous tapez de biologie en
anglais donc dans wikipédia on tomberait
à un moment sur toutes les différentes
enfin les sous-domaines les disciplines
qui adore la géologie donc ça j'essaie
de donner un aperçu d'un peu tout et
puis j'essaye dans l'idéal j'aimerais
bien essayer de montrer quels indices on
trouve sur le terrain et comment on
arrive à remonter a par exemple
l'histoire géologique d'une région ça
j'essaye un peu d'en parler dans ma
prochaine vidéo donc ce genre de truc
pour moi c'est un peu expliqué un peu la
boîte à outils du géologue et quel est
son raisonnement
mais après dans le détail à passer
a expliqué le détail de la méthode
scientifique et où je vais pas
m'attarder trop trop là dessus même si
dans la dernière je reviens un peu sur
les principes de la science
expérimentale donc genre rasseoir
d'ockham tous ces trucs là donc j'essaie
de d'infuser impôts des petits trucs jeu
ce que je dis là contredit ce que j'ai à
dire au début mais je réfléchis et c'est
aussi bordélique dans ma tête que dans
mes scripts majoration est et ouest du
coup j'essaye un petit peu de bah ouais
de distiller un peu de l'envers du décor
de la recherche dans mes vidéos mais
c'est pas non plus le but principal et
c'est même une de mes peurs c'est de
rendre la géologie un peu trop cool par
rapport à ce que c'est et que les gens
finissent par aller là bas parce que je
fais des vidéos cool et enfin cool et
qu'ils soient déçus après après ça
dépend des gens parce que moi perso je
ne suis pas déçu en études de géologie
là je sais pas j'ai passé la semaine
dernière deux énormes bouquin académique
de géologie et gt gt matinée j'étais
comme une gamine quoi donc c'est
possible
ne perdez pas être ça peut être bien ça
mais du coup ça y est vous êtes si
jamais vous êtes bacheliers que vous
envisagez des études de géologie ne vous
basez pas que sur mes vidéos pour vous
orienter allait quand même jeter un oeil
à des vrais bas ne serait ce que des
pages wikipedia de darty enfin outre
pierre roger moore si ça vous plaît pas
voilà qui conseille le guide cracher
votre dos cachez pas votre vie en
faisant des choix sans vous renseigner
ça ne veut pas dire que vous avez gâché
vous dit si vous deviez géologue ans je
tiens à préciser pour ceux qui viennent
tout juste de débarquer bonjour au point
génisses et bonjour à cette enquête et à
bas après tout il ya entre web et je me
semble que ton prénom et antoine non
puisque j'étais vue sur le live de ckoi
c'est quoi cette bébête hier qu'ils
demandent si tu vas voir des vidéos sur
la pédologie et la paix de jeunesse à et
bah écoute ça fait partie des trucs sur
ma liste c'est pas pour tout de suite
mais ça fait partie de mes pour ceux qui
ne sont pas géologue versa pédologie ce
rêve est une des soldes
elle parce qu'en fait le sol on pense
que c'est complètement con c'est juste
de la terre mais en fait non c'est pas
du tout de la terre il ya plein de
couches différentes ce qu'on appelle des
horizons et il ya plein de réactions
enfin il ya plein de processus physico
chimiques dans le sol pour créer le sol
en fait et tous les saints ne sont pas
les mêmes ça dépend des conditions
climatiques des de la végétation qui
as-tu fin il ya des tas et des tas de
trucs à dire et notamment il ya un type
de sol qui s'appelle puzzle et j'aime
beaucoup ce mot là et du coup c'est sûr
que ce sera dans une de mes vidéos
voilà il ya libéraux 8 qui demandent si
tu aurais des come stay de géologues
pour faire bourgeois ricochet alors je
vais raconter cette histoire
la dernière fois j'étais enfin la
dernière fois que j'étais à la plage
avec des amis sur une plage de galets on
m'a fait des ricochets et je faisais les
pires ricochet au monde genre y avait
même pas ses limites si touchez jamais
le terran mais l'eau donc je ne donnerai
pas de compte je pense que c'est plus
une histoire dynamique et de tension de
surface que se passe-t-il mais oui
faudrait faire une vidéo rien que là
dessus n'empêche c'est maintenant sa
décision
oui propos de la pédologie juste j'en
profite pour raconter un petit débat qui
a en interne dans le monde des géologues
en fait c'est une espèce de racisme à
l'intérieur de la géologie
j'utilise tous les mots qu'il faut pas
que tu me remercieras il ya ceux qui
travaillent sur le quaternaire donc
c'est les étapes d'être le récente de la
vie de la terre et puis ceux qui
travaillent sur les choses des plus
anciennes et les plus anciens enfin ceux
qui travaillent sur les choses de plus
anciennes se considèrent comme des vrais
géologue alors que le quaternaire
ils sont plus vus comme la limite des
archéologues coiffante eu assez des
trucs c'est pas des régions et la
pédologie en fait partie justement but
c'est pour ça que j'essaye de lutter
contre cette espèce de discrimination
intra intra disciplinaire est-ce que
c'est aussi la dernière vidéo c'est le
sable que j'ai fait c'est du quaternaire
donc enfin ça se rapproche à des se
rapportent à des processus
géomorphologiques qu'on appelle ou
sédimentologiques et donc ça c'est
typiquement du matériel et j'adore ça je
lutte contre ce côté un peu le côté
renaer c'est pas les filles
c'est pour les vraies bonnes âmes quoi
bomber a détaillé on a rajouté le
machisme dans le lot donc c'est bien
commencé à voir une belle pile sur notre
sueur de baie comeau et anthony de la
voilà les vrais sujets non on n'est pas
là pour parler des détails de la
géologie on est là pour parler d'humour
j'apprécie tout à fait des distinctions
ceci dit moi je pense que c'est super
intéressant d'entendre la façon dont
certaines branches peuvent se tirer la
bourre comme on dit par chez nous c'est
intéressant
et le pire c'est pardon j'arrête après
on désire pas de souci j'ai remarqué
qu'ils veulent la même chose dans
plusieurs disciplines géant tu prends
les historiens je crois que c'est manon
qui racontait que si tu travailles sur
l'antiquité et battait des mal vu qu'on
parlait à ceux qui travaillent sur la
paléontologie enfin dans les hangars
talent et tous ces trucs là quoi tu vois
pas ce que tu travailles sur des
poussées à récentes qui sont tombés hier
ses marques il ya ça dans tous les
domaines quand j'imagine qu'à la même
chose en physique ceux qui travaillent
sur j'espère le big bang et s considère
supérieur aux autres je ne sais pas il
faudrait demander aux gens que c'est
absolument pas justifié un je tiens à le
rappeler quand même il ya le point
genius qui dit ah bah si on est dans les
conseils jusqu'à part avancé le moment
blagues dans le tchat
j'avais acheté un diamant à ma copine
mais je préfère garder mes sous pour
m'acheter un truc pour moi tu as un
caillou gratos qui ressemble un diamant
pur matin ils sont un peu loin mais
c'est d'en parler dans les magasins de
décoration
tu peux acheter ils font des gros
diamant comme ça en plastoc et et c'est
très joli
il faut juste que tu montes en eau mag
sinon tu peux pourquoi oui sinon tu
prends ça voilà et tu lui dis c'est un
diamant avant transformation car tu as à
transformer mon coeur je sais pas ça
c'est bien mais on en est là je pense
que tu tiens quelque chose effectivement
à retrouver sur mon chariot type aller
sur son ultime en termes de d'humour
d'humour scientifique tu n'hésitais pas
forcément beaucoup de références mais on
va creuser un peu plus loin quand même
histoire de te mettre bien au pied de
ton ignorance plaisante il ya plein de
façons d'explorer l'humour dans les
sciences on a la chance ont donc j'avais
mentionné deux tomes l'erreur on a
évidemment les sketchs mais on a aussi
le dessin je pense évidemment ex-cat cd
mais il y en a bien d'autres est ce que
toi tu as des références dans des médias
autre que les sketches qui te plaisent
particulièrement pour ce qui est de la
transmission de défiance en humour
ah bah je crois que la reine là dedans
c'est tu mourras moins bête
marion montaigne elle fait des trucs
incroyables et aboulaye aussi qui fait
des trucs fantastiques
après il ya je ne sais pas ce que j'en
ai fait il ya patrick bot qui a sorti
une bd avec sale chaussures sur des
bestioles insolites et leurs moyens de
reproduction ignoble et très triste et
du coup c'est assez drôle jce q comment
s'appelle le bestiaire extraordinaire je
rentre comme ça et il est vraiment bien
donc je suis ravie quand il ya des
dessinateurs qui se mettent à vulgariser
quand c'est les pieds
ce que je trouve intéressant c'est la
capacité de l'humour à rendre soudain la
transmission scientifique un peu
intergénérationnel c'est à dire que tu
prendrais une bd qui serait dédié à
transmettre un contenu scientifique une
un biopic ou autre généralement va se
fixer sur une tranche d'âge en
particulier alors qu'avec le mourre d'un
coup j'ai l'impression contre
décloisonne énormément et qu'on peut
toucher beaucoup plus de monde sais pas
si tu as cette expérience avec ta chaîne
ou d'autre chose que tu peux produire
oui oui je touche beaucoup de monde dont
des enfants et oui c'est ça qui est bien
c'est que ça parle absolument à tous et
il est même les gens de ma famille qui
s'intéresse absolument pas aussi en ce
qui regarde mes vidéos parce que il
rigole quoi donc
ils disent ces corps la suivante ces
commotions donc oui j'ai l'impression
que ça touche vraiment beaucoup de monde
et ça c'est cool j'essaye aussi d'y
faire un peu attention dans mais dans
mes vidéos c'est à dire que j'allais
dire j'essaye de ne pas mettre trop gros
mots et pas tous comme ça parce que je
sais que ça peut potentiellement toucher
d un public jeune et en même temps je
fais des blagues ignoble donc ça colle
pas vous c'est un type elle dit en gros
que des maris sûr je fais le fait
qu'elle est certes faire attention même
temps on n'est pas là oui voilà
et puis bon je regardais ce parc j'avais
moins de 10 ans donc un les enfants sont
pas si fragile ce qui explique peut-être
des trucs
je veux pas tirer des conclusions
hâtives parce que ça va trop loin à
nouveau la réplique à l'expérience c'est
ouais non non c'est intéressant je
trouve cette capacité de toucher des
générations de façon de façon plus large
est ce que toi dans ton expérience je
trouve que l'humour est encore trop
absent à l'intérieur du milieu
scientifique même est ce que tu penses
qu'ils auraient besoin qu'il y en ait
plus soit ce n'est pas forcément
nécessaire à l'intérieur du milieu
scientifique tu veux dire milieu de la
recherche aux milliers de la recherche
notamment pour comment dire pour recréer
un petit peu de transversalité puisque
c'est vrai qu'on a des spécialités qui
se précise de plus en plus et on a
tendance à perdre
cette approche le transverse des
sciences et peut-être aussi pour
faciliter la capacité de vulgarisation
de certains chercheurs
alors c'est une question assez difficile
que tu me pose là disons que auprès du
grand public je pense que ça peut être
un bon levier
après dans le milieu de la recherche ou
dans l'enseignement
ça dépend parce que il ya le risque de
se décrédibiliser et enfin voila j'ai
l'impression qu'il cherche enfin les
chercheurs j'ai fait une grosse
généralités il ya antoine en particulier
ceux qui travaillent sur le côté voilà
écrit les pédologue là j'ai l'impression
que d'expérience j'ai l'impression que
la majorité des chercheurs je prends
tellement de penser que j'ai pu creuser
tenait quand même à alleur leur
crédibilité et du coup ils vont
peut-être pas à rigoler à tout va et
faire d'énormes blague même si j'en ai
eu dans mes profs et quand ils achètent
c'était beaucoup mieux mais du coup j'ai
l'impression que qui sont peut-être un
peu frileux de ce point de vue là parce
que il ya aussi le fait que je fais
vraiment de la sociologie de comptoir là
je suis vraiment désolé mais antoine
besoin que de mal pour lui quand même
moi j'ai l'impression aussi qu' il ya le
côté tout peuple et celle des riches que
tu trouves dans la science ou les
chercheurs sont amenés à toujours être
en compétition contre les uns contre les
autres donc peut-être à se montrer sous
leur meilleur facettes et et pas baisser
leur garde et du coup peut-être que ce
serait pour ça qu'ils feraient moins de
moins 2
blague qui pourrait faire après c'est
vraiment juste mon opinion vous voilà il
n'y a aucune recherche derrière aucune
je sais même pas si représentatif de
quoi que ce soit parce que après
personne je donne des cours
je donne quelques cours à la fac à paris
diderot et là pour le coup c'est
quasiment comme nous comme dans mes
vidéos quand je fais des blagues tout le
temps et je suis gêné mais propre cour
je suis plié en deux et c'est que les
élèves comprennent pas et du coup je
rigole encore plus c'est terrible mais
mais du coup j'ai l'impression que ça
empêche pas l'information de passer
quand même donc pourquoi pas après je
n'explique pas des trucs ultra compliqué
qu'on ouais donc c'est ça aussi
quand tu rentre vraiment dans un sujet
extrêmement pointu c'est difficile d'où
peut-être c'est bon je sais pas je pense
que tu aurais fait partie de mes profs
préféré moi je me souviens encore et je
pense que c'est un essai seul prof dont
je retiens encore le nom aujourd'hui
c'était mon prof de neurophysiologie
monsieur gilles chevalier que je que je
salue avec mon infinie respect qui était
très drôle et qui se servait beaucoup de
l'humour d'une pour nous maintenir
engagé en cours mais si pour nous faire
comprendre certaines choses et une fois
je me souviens et voulait nous parler de
la communication neurochimique et ils
voulaient nous expliquer la différence
entre la communication neuronale et le
système endocrinien
les différences de communication et il
nous a dit le système endocrinien c'est
un petit peu comme si je voulais dire un
secret à telle personne qui est dans
l'amphithéâtre et que je faisais et j'ai
un secret à d alors que la communication
de ronald et là il allait faire son
petit son petit chemin jusqu'à la nava
pour lui dire le secret on était pliée
de rire et je m'en souviens encore et je
pense que c'est vraiment un outil
d'éducation qui est qui est super
important et qui mériterait d'être
introduits dans les amphithéâtres
après l'humour n'est pas un talent chez
tout le monde oui voilà
et il doit se pratiquer avec raison
peut-être aussi que j'appelle la chance
d'avoir des profs
hilarant par contre j'ai vu des profs
qui genre quitte raconte un truc qui
n'est pas forcément en lien avec avec le
sujet mais juste qui t'apprennent des
choses sur la vie et ça c'est juste
incroyable bon dit comme ça ça fait
bizarre aussi mais genre qui m'explique
que le système de sélection à la fac qui
n'est pas basé sur les savoirs que tu va
acquérir mais plus sur le fait que tu es
capable d'apprendre des trucs et de
comprendre et de raisonner et de
restituer un raisonnement
oui bah ça il nous l'a expliqué essam a
man blue quoi et ça reste un de mes
profs préféré aujourd'hui parce qu'en
fait il essayait de nous enseigner des
valeurs sûres sur la recherche sur la
vie et tout et c'est cool et c'est aussi
ce genre de truc que j'essaie de faire
dans des cours après les malheurs que je
transmets ce n'est peut-être pas
forcément le meilleur
et je trouve que c'est aussi important
que transmettre des savoirs
il ya antoine qui dit il ya beaucoup
d'humour référencé chez les
scientifiques par rapport aux références
culturelles le s p g avait fait une expo
la science une histoire d'humour où les
scientifiques devaient venir avec leurs
blagues et les coller dans l'expo est ce
que tu as des blagues de géologues
appartement ou là ou là là là là je
redoutais cette crise tu n'es pas obligé
de très mauvaise blague en blague près
préfète et j'ai aucune mémoire donc bon
question suivante 2 0 non mais alors tu
vois je vais revenir sur la question de
de l'humour dans le milieu de la
recherche même si tu es c'était pas
forcément le coeur du sujet
d'aujourd'hui mais ce que je constate
c'est cahors quoique il y a beaucoup
d'initiatives de chercheurs qui font de
l'humour et qui créent des hashtag
amusant sur sur twitter pour communiquer
les sciences et je trouve que ça
décloisonne énormément la communication
en 3d la boe entre les chercheurs et que
ça crée une collaboration qui est
vraiment inattendu je sais pas si tu as
fait le même constat
oui tout à fait oui il ya une initiative
que j'ai trouvé génial c'était le sr en
peinture donc nécessaire pour
l'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
et les gens partager des tableaux en
légendant avec des légendes qui
correspondait qu'il correspondait à leur
sert donc là comme ça j'ai pas d'exemple
c'est hyper intéressant je sais plus le
meilleur tu as vingt tableaux avec
quelqu'un qui est en train de mourir et
c'était les gens des genres en train de
faire une demande de financement à ener1
des trucs c'est beaucoup plus drôle que
ce que je raconte là si vous tapez le
nom du hasch réactions sur google vous
tourne le répète sur un article le récap
du monde ou un truc comme ça et il ya
plein d'exemples je crois que c'est
david wark est lancé ce hashtag en plus
il me semble il en avait lancé en tout
cas d' endroit il ya ph qui pose une
question et je vais me permettre de la
compléter ph il dit
est ce que tu as déjà été victime de
discrimination en tant que femme et donc
j'aimerais aller plus loin en disant est
ce que l'humour tu a permis d'éviter la
discrimination en tant que femme
justement parce que on ne percevait pas
comme quelqu'un qui était juste là pour
se montrer comme une belle personne à
l'écran comme on peut avoir ce genre de
clichés ça je saurai pas de dire de
toute façon il faudrait me clonés et si
jamais je venais une jumelle il faudrait
qu'elle a la même chaîne que moi mais
sans l'humour est comme ça on pourra
comparer mais je ne serai pas de dire
par contre je sais que moi je fais des
blagues sur moi même j'en ai même
ferdinand enfin sur mon poids et tout ça
et je me suis dit allez j'y vais
francour on va voir comment ça réagit
dans les commentaires et j'ai pas eu de
réflexion là-dessus spécial
spécifiquement et j'ai jamais eu de fin
je n'ai jamais eu de problème
gg que des gens extrêmement bienveillant
qui soit sur ma chaîne ou même jeu
j'étais passé à la fin d'une vidéo d'
astronomique
et quand on regarde dans ses
commentaires parce qu'il ya des gens un
petit peu hardcore dans sa communauté
comme et non il y avait que des trucs
sympas sur moi donc bon quelques petits
trucs sexistes sur des bords mais ça
passe ce n'était pas statistiquement
significatif je pense mais non
globalement j'ai beaucoup de chance je
pense aussi que je suis partagé par des
gens qui ont des bonnes communauté donc
j'ai pas trop ce souci et j'en suis très
heureuse je le vis bien de ton
expérience est ce que ce qui va le mieux
marché pour communiquer une information
c'est de créer d'humour autour de
l'information en elle même ou autour du
scientifique et de sa démarche est ce
que tu vas plutôt utilisé un retard ou
l'autre par exemple est ce que tu vas
plutôt créé d'humour autour de la
situation de revenir sur le terrain par
exemple ou plus tôt
je sais pas faire une blague de cailloux
quoi commenterai dont on extrait de
vidéo qu'il a c'est délicat
je pense que je fais plutôt des blagues
complètement décorrélée du sujet parce
que j'aime bien justement les gens
restent pas dans le dans le cadre je
parle de géologie et j'aime bien faire
des liens entre justement le domaine et
enfin ce que j'explique ou des
mécanismes et des taux comme ça et des
trucs qui n'ont absolument rien à voir
pour pas rester cloisonné justement à ce
domaine
d'accord je sais pas si ça répond à ta
question je pense que ça y répond à ta
manière la marque dans ton style et
j'aime bien la 3ds man qui dit parce que
vous savez combien de chercheurs il faut
pour changer une ampoule je la connais
celle là non edit un seul mais il y
avait 300 candidatures
une bonne façon de dédramatiser enfin
j'ai pas si on peut la dédramatiser mais
de se détendre un peu c'est sur la
situation d'un coup quand j'ai fait le
tour de mes questions à dire vrai je
vais pas recommencer a beau fouiller
comme j'ai fait dans le live avec cette
pauvre mari est ce que tu as des
remarques à faire est ce que tu as des
des choses à dire sur ce que l'humour tu
as apporté dans la vulgarisation ce que
tu as ce que ça t'a apporté en terme de
communauté aussi cite une note une
différence de communautés par rapport à
d'autres personnes qui utiliseraient
peut-être pas autant l'humour une
différence de communauté le truc c'est
que je reste pas je fais pas trop trop
gaffe à mes stops sache une mauvaise
quand il est dans les clous type de
commentaires que nous avons dans les
commentaires bah j'ai des gens vraiment
de tout bord et coin sens de l'humour
donc ça c'est ça me ravit et j'ai des
gens aussi qui se sentent enfin qu
essayer de faire des blagues et du coup
ça me fait rire aussi
donc c'est que j'ai l'impression que
l'humour c'est justement ce qui nous lie
les uns aux autres ça c'est cool et ça
me fait plaisir aussi d'avoir quelques
retours de géologues des fois qu'ils me
disent qu'ils ont bien aimé qu'ils ont
bien appris en fin de bail justement
dans qu'ils ont rien appris parce que
ils savent déjà tout mais
mais qui faisait rigoler c'est cool j'ai
même des retours de gens qui utilisent
mes vidéos des profs qui utilisent les
vidéos en cours donc ça c'est un peu
vache m'enfin ça me fait super plaisir
quoi la dernière sur le sable je pense
que des bugs un petit peu trop hardcore
pour que ça passe dans les courbes en
salle de classe
j'hésite en les faisant puis je me suis
dit allez y au lot voilà sinon
j'aimerais juste revenir sur un message
qui a écrit antoine dans le tchat
bruno latour écrit que le sociologue des
sciences s'étonne toujours que la
science des sols ne soit pas devenue
l'une des sciences majeur ce qui est
quand même très exagérées admettons que
je suis d'accord c'est exagéré mais je
salue ton courage d'aller faire de la
bio éthique pour mon travail j'ai
l'impression que c'est quelqu'un qui
très très exhaustif dans sa manière de
de suivre les généraux en plus des vues
sur le live avec pierre querniard hier
il était à ce sujet là j'ai écrit un
billet de blog
allez allez voir sur mon blog d'ailleurs
tu as failli te faire ce traqué par par
pierre karner j'ai bien vu qu'il était
bref à la la je suis pas drôle c'est
merveilleux je trouve ça intéressant
l'idée que que l'humour crée du lien
comme tu le disais que ça que ça
rapproche les gens et que ça crée un
lien entre toi communicatrice et
scientifique et le public
je sais que enfin d'expérience dans
youtube on retrouve ça dans des
communautés où les gens vont vraiment se
poser et prendre le temps d'expliquer
avoir une approche qui est très
personnel mais j'aime bien le fait que
tu puisse créer ce type de relation sans
forcément avoir un aimant c'est un
investissement émotionnel très fort mais
au contraire en utilisant l'humour pour
encore une fois je pense créer une forme
de deux des complexes décomplexion pour
moins pour que les gens soient
sentiments complexes et voilà oui mais
je sais ça qui est bien là effectivement
il ya un fort lien entre entre les
jambes ma communauté et moi même mais
oui j'ai l'impression qu'il ya beaucoup
d'engagement comme on dit aujourd'hui
et ça ça me fera plaisir et en même
temps il ya beaucoup de personnel dans
mes blagues parce que c'est très souvent
des dépravés joke ou des trucs kourou où
je me mets en pensait nous d'être comme
ça non je me gilles ouimet beaucoup
d'une langue et peut-être que
ça marcherait moi en tout cas ça me
plairait - s'il y avait moins de deux
mois dans mes blagues quoi c'est
affreusement prétentieuse que je ne
soyons pas bon c'est super intéressant
moi si on mettait les pieds dans le plat
pour les cinq minutes qui nous reste
comment est ce que tu dirais qu'elle
approche du futur va prendre alors
puisque je pense ne pas avoir vu une
vidéo pour l'instant qui mentionne trop
le confinement est là qu vide
quelle approche qui prendrait doit
pouvoir rapport à ça pour que on arrive
à redescendre un petit peu de cet état
de je vais reprendre ton mot panique qui
a été créée parce qu'on en a vraiment
besoin je pense de dédramatiser la
situation on en parlait avec avec tania
les gens en arrivent à se renseigner sur
des choses qui sont hyper pointu mais à
côté n'emploie pas forcément les bonnes
comme on appelle ça déjà un flûte les
aider les trucs de distance et sociales
qui sont proposés c'est fou on entend de
mesures merci les messieurs les mesures
dernières tensions
on entend tellement balancé par tous que
ça finit par telle démarche tian
emploierez humoristiquement pour que
justement les gens soient moins
angoissée à et moins chercher dans le
détail de l'information mais à côté de
ça renforce leur mesure de précaution
comment est ce que tu te verrai utiliser
l'humour dans cette optique la peine
question plus compliqué maintenant alors
rien à voir mais juste qui me fait
penser parce qu'on faisait ça pour
rigoler une autre source d'inspiration
que gmail youtube poop c'est juste une
mine d'information extraordinaire ça n'a
rien à la question mais j'y reviendrai
si vous regardez sur youtube vous tapez
y tp et puis vous pouvez taper par
exemple nounours et est en fait c'est
une manière de remonter de faire des
détournements de vidéo qui existe c'est
une culture pour leur faire dire autre
chose
et souvent c'est affreusement
irrévérencieux et même un petit peu
vulgaire l'issue je ne recommande pas
celle chose dans cette grosse grosse
source d'information et d'inspiration je
dirais donc pour répondre à ta question
moi ce que j'aime et bien c'est à un
moment je regardais les youtube poop
qu'ils avaient sur les discours de
macron et en même temps ça peut
encourager un peu le la défiance qu'on
peut avoir vis-à-vis du gouvernement
après ces biens ne sait pas bien mais du
coup ça nage vite peut-être pas à
respecter les mesures de sécurité fins
de conciliation ont échoué tôt après
ouais je pense les mêmes qui se baladent
battu c'est drôle ça ça peut aider
c'est un ensemble en gros tout ce qu'ils
possèdent à servir à faire passer de
l'humour une paume utiliser quoi donc
voilà je jouais pas mieux comme comme
réponse désolé mais y'a pas de soucis
moi je suis je suis une chanteuse
britannique s'appelle d'audi et qui
avait créé une chanson qui se voulait un
petit peu rigolote pour pour que les
gens se souviennent de se laver les
mains notamment je pense que la
répétition et la mise en chanson peuvent
jouer un rôle super important pour juste
imprimé dans le cerveau de tout le monde
peut pas dire des gens j'aime pas ce
terme que déjà on est toujours en
confinement techniquement quand bien
même on les confine il faut qu'il faut
rester prudent que il faut pas stresser
que voilà je pense que l'humour peut
jouer un rôle super important pour parce
que en fait j'ai lu un article super
intéressant là dessus sur slate
il ya quelques jours qu'ils avaient été
relayées par elodie chabrol qui disait
la science aujourd'hui elle ses tableaux
teasé salué le dit la science
aujourd'hui s'est politisée et
malheureusement enfin malheureusement ne
disait pas malheureusement mais je dis
malheureusement la science a besoin
d'avoir recours à des à des ressorts
émotionnels aujourd'hui pour toucher un
public et je pense que le mort est l'un
des ressorts émotionnels le plus honnête
dans le sens où ça va pas essayer de
jouer sûreté des prises de parti mais
que ça va simplement dédramatiser et au
moment en même temps créer un
investissement émotionnel suffisamment
fort pour faire passer un message sans
pour autant essayer de l'influencer dans
un sens ou dans l'autre ce que
j'apprécie beaucoup
en fait et je pense que c'est une des
meilleures options pour pour véhiculer
les sciences
tout à fait en parlant de chansons ça me
fait penser pardon mais il ya une des
dernières vidéos de sayoud son rôle je
sais plus laquelle ou à la fin ils se
filment en train de refaire la
chorégraphie tu sais la chorégraphie de
lavage de mains qui est vietnamienne aux
coréens je sais que ça aussi c'est
raciste je pense pas ce que j'ai à dire
et et du couple s'était filmé en train
de refaire la chorégraphie et
et il est vraiment très très fort je
sais pas si la petite lumière rouge
s'allumer là du coup c'est juste
extraordinaire et il est tellement bon
que maintenant je pense à lui quand je
m'engage les mois passent et
l'informaticien
bon bah écoute
il nous reste deux minutes moi
j'aimerais vous proposer de finir en
chanson j'ai une petite surprise pour
vous à la fin alors attaqué qui dit je
ne sais pas exemple de santé publique et
d' influence des populations la
prévention contre le tabac ça a marché
parce qu'il faisait peur aux rires ça et
le prix du paquet de clopes à savoir moi
je sais que quitte à employer des
ressorts des ressorts psychologiques je
préfère passer par l'humour parce que ça
maintient de la bienveillance et puis de
toute façon ça permet d'ancrer des
émotions positives
je pense qu'on a tous envie de fuir la
peur est d'aller dans le sens des
émotions positives donc c'est pour ça
aussi qu'on est là pour parler de ça
aujourd'hui c'est je pense que vraiment
le l'humour est quelque chose de
puissant et probablement encore une fois
l'un des meilleurs ressorts pour créer
de l'investissement émotionnel sans
créer de la manipulation ou des commença
désencrage négatif chez les personnes
alors techniquement si je puis me
permettre
il ya une petite manipulation derrière
quand même hein ça s'appelle la théorie
de la manipulation sociale
c'est un des rôles du rire justement
c'est à dire que quand on fait rire
quelqu'un on améliore son image auprès
de cette personne et on améliore le lien
de confiance entre nous donc c'est aussi
une manière de manipuler un petit peu
mais oui alors sur elle il ya
manipulation
enfin tu as à bon escient ou pas quoi et
ça c'est une autre question
non alors pour le coup je disais
manipulation de plus tôt par rapport aux
enfin oui non tu me diras ça reste un
outil mais sur les sur les idées
notamment c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas
besoin d'aller chercher des idées
spécifiques pour créer une réaction de
la colère de l'enthousiasmé autres la
planète des blagues et pas toujours
neutre mais la blague a le pouvoir
d'être neutre et de créer de
l'investissement ce que je trouve super
intéressant oui voila merci beaucoup
d'avoir et merci à vous c'était
silhouette
merci à tous dans le chatt c'était super
cool d'avoir ce moment blague avec vous
je trouve qu'on s'est bien marré et donc
et comme promis je vais vous laisser
chanson avec une chanson de tom l'erreur
qui s'appelle dit alain boumsong que
vous connaissez peut-être et je vous ai
même mis les paroles pour que vous
puissiez la chanter chez vous bonne
journée à tous merci d'avoir suivi ce
premier épisode du salon de thé qui est
en fait le 8e et puis on se retrouve en
juin puisque le calendrier du café des
sciences va changer un petit peu le café
des sciences va continuer de mettre des
contenus en live mais pour ma part je
déménage donc on se retrouve en juin
avec un nouveau décor et avec agata du
nid de pie bonne journée à tous et à
bientôt
[Musique]